beim ndr gibt es die nächsten skandal
war den öffentlich rechtlichen
diesmal betrifft es eben den
norddeutschen rundfunk dort beklagen
mehrere mitarbeiter jetzt die fehlende
freiheit in ihrer berichterstattung
das berichtet business insider die ja
auch teil von axel springer hier sind ja
und es heißt es herrsche dort ein klima
der angst auch von einem politischen
filter ist dort die rede kritische
politische themen würden frühzeitig die
relevanz abgesprochen der ndr der weiß
diese vorwürfe zurück sie sprechen von
einer unvoreingenommenen und
unabhängigen berichterstattung die
aufregung bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen
nach dem skandal rund um patricia
schlesinger wir wissen es alle jetzt
also diese vorwürfe die kritik sie reist
also nicht ab
[Musik]